STEAL OR RENT VANS AND USE THEM
TO ATTACK CIVILIANS.
>> Sean: THANK YOU.
JOINING US WITH MORE REACTION
FROM THE HILL, JOE CONCHA.
FORMER DEPUTY ASSISTANT
DR. SEBASTIAN GORKA.
DR. GORKA, THE JUSTICE
DEPARTMENT INVESTIGATING COMEY.
CRIMINAL REFERRALS ON EVERY TOP
FIGURE.
LYNCH, HILLARY HERSELF.
COMEY, McCABE, LISA PAGE,
PETER STRZOK.
THE IG CRIMINAL REFERRAL AS IT
RELATES TO McCABE.
ALL WE HAVE TALKED ABOUT IS
HAPPENING.
EVERYTHING THE MEDIA HAS TALKED
ABOUT HAS BEEN WRONG.
>> YES, ABSOLUTELY.
FOR THE LAST 14 MONTHS.
LET'S TIE IT TOGETHER.
THE JIGSAW PUZZLE MUST BE MADE
INTO A FULL PICTURE.
WE KNOW ANDREW McCARTHY'S
HYPOTHESIS IS SOUND.
IT'S CLEAR THE OBAMA
ADMINISTRATION WANTED HILLARY TO
WIN.
SHE WAS PROTECTED BY THE HIGHEST
ECHELONS OF DOJ AND FBI BECAUSE
HER FELONIOUS USE OF A PRIVATE
SERVER TO SEND CLASSIFIED
INFORMATION ON IMPLICATED THE
PRESIDENT HIMSELF.
WE KNOW PRESIDENT OBAMA UNDER A
PSEUDONYM CONTACTED HER AND SENT
SENSITIVE INFORMATION ON THE
PRIVATE SERVER WHICH MEANT WHICH
MEANT IF SHE WAS PROSECUTED,
GUESS WHO HAS TO BE PROSECUTED
AS WELL.
PRESIDENT OBAMA.
THAT'S WHY THEY PERVERTED THE
COURSE OF JUSTICE AND EVERYTHING
SHOULD BE RENAMED NOT FISA-GATE,
NOT SURVEILLANCE-GATE.
IT MUST BE RENAMED OBAMA-GATES.
>> Sean: DEEP STATE, OBAMA
GATE, WHATEVER YOU WANT.
YOU FOLLOW THE MEDIA AND THEIR
COVERAGE.
NOT EXPECTING AN APOLOGY BUT THE
LEVEL OF RECKLESS HYSTERIA
ESPECIALLY ON THE CABLE
NETWORKS, NOT FOX, AND IN
"THE WASHINGTON POST" AND
"NEW YORK TIMES."
ANONYMOUS SOURCES, FAKE NEWS.
CONSPIRACY THEORIES.
THIS REPRESENTS NEWS IN AMERICA?
>> "THE NEW YORK TIMES" MY
BIGGEST COMPLAINT AMONG READERS,
AND IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR YEARS
AND YEARS, IS THE USE OF
ANONYMOUS SOURCES.
THE AFTER RELIANCE ON THEM.
USUALLY THE MOTIVE IS PROBABLY
NEFARIOUS.
THEY ARE NOT INNOCENT
WHISTLE-BLOWERS.
LOOKING TO PUSH THE NARRATIVE TO
HURT PEOPLE IN POSITIONS OF